[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
funziona bene
ottimo allora
buonasera a tutti sono sarà ricciardi
sono liner progetto uno studio a milano
progetto solitamente oggetti
installazioni interni spazi e poi ad un
certo punto della mia carriera ho avuto
la fortuna di incontrare il social
design che cambia totalmente il
paradigma social design non funziona più
come qualcosa che nasce da una
fascinazione personale no non si va a
progetti aree
con materiali nel prodotto si parte
sempre da quelle che definiamo anche
delle ricerche delle intuizioni che si
fanno anche da una scrivania invece il
social design ti invita ad uscire fuori
e a mappare delle esigenze esterne ad
entrare in contatto con quelle che sono
le persone i contesti sempre variabili
in continua trasformazione e quindi in
questi casi io amo definirmi un
attivatore sociale un attivatore sociale
è colui che cerca di facilitare delle
dinamiche che ci sono al al suo esterno
vorrei partire appunto parlandovi di
quello che anche il mio percorso
pedagogico che ogni giorno esploro
perché lavorare con gli studenti
alimentarsi continuamente continua
ricerca e con loro tentò di applicare un
metodo che oggi ho piacere un po a
mostrarvi una delle prime parole che
introducono i corsi e agirà cioè ragazzi
dovete agire
dovete fare hanno tutti molta paura
all'inizio ai delle persone trattenute
perché hanno paura di commettere un
errore un errore che poi non si sa come
gestire io invece dico agitate esplorate
sbagliate e quindi una volta fece questo
esperimento ieri a loro questo foglio
azzurro e gli disse guardatelo questo
foglio azzurro piatto sul vostro banco
allora ho provato a fare un'azione è
cosa succede allora tutti un po anche
chi timidamente chi meno iniziarono a
fare proprio un un atto un atto sul
foglio e quell'atto è capace di generare
altre forme forme che erano tutte è
totalmente diverse l'una dall'altra io
le amo definire delle delle onde no
allora le onde si generano un po come il
vento che arriva a generare queste
queste onde sulla superficie è
interessante capire come ognuno di noi
puo generare tramite un atto personale
delle onde allora un'altra cosa
importantissima è il caos ricordare la
frase in principio era il caos che è il
luogo dove tutto nasce non dobbiamo
essere spaventati da entrare in questi
deliri di informazioni e possibilità
questa cosa ci deve dobbiamo
abbandonarci a questi contesti con delle
particolari situazioni umorali la prima
è la fiducia perché non essere fiducioso
in qualcosa se affrontiamo qualcosa come
una certa fiducia allora le dinamiche
davanti a noi possono iniziare ad essere
fibrillanti in maniera positiva questa
cosa si ottiene anche divertendoci
perché un'altra cosa che tra l'altro mi
sorprende molto negli studenti e che li
vedo sempre afflitti da chissà quale
divertitevi
divertitevi fate divertendovi perché è
importante coltivare questa questa forza
questa carica per esplorare quindi il
caos generativo lo chiamo
diciamo che io amo andare nei contesti
che
hanno questo pullulare di elementi e mi
spiace che le persone riescano a in
queste potenzialità che ci sono perché
le potenzialità anche questa sarà
davvero infinite
però bisogna selezionare quindi una
delle prime cose nell'agire è quindi
aggrapparsi a delle degli oggetti delle
dei punti e farli propri per una
narrativa personale perché tutti noi
quando facciamo le cose raccontiamo una
storia una storia che è sempre personale
perché dipende dalle nostre capacità le
nostre esperienze e ciò che riusciamo a
raccogliere in quel momento dal
dall'ambiente esterno
allora io vi porto un po in giro in
quelli che sono stati dei workshop che
hanno segnato delle parole chiave per il
mio percorso di designer questo è
l'istituto di igiene mentale di berlino
dove ci hanno chiamato
eravamo io e wei wei il mio collega
cinese in cui ci chiesero lì i pazienti
vanno tutti i giorni per lavorare e
percepire uno stipendio solitamente
fanno azioni ripetitive
mettili berline fino alle perline fanno
azioni che possano sedare no degli
ipotetici animi troppo emotivi e ci
chiesero però di fare un laboratorio
come volevamo all'interno del centro di
ceramica e applichiamo questo approccio
lì gli strumenti che si potevano
utilizzare erano completamente
improbabili quindi avevamo pennelli il
progetto si chiama the pancake project
proprio perché si affida a una sorta di
di come una sperimentazione in cucina
felice e divertente in cui ognuno dei
nostri partecipanti al workshop poteva
approcciare in maniera un po
irriverente a quello che era fare dei
piatti da commercializzare in germania
qui si attiva tutta una parte di gesto
di essere di queste persone che iniziano
anche a trovare un divertimento nel
lavorare all'interno del laboratorio
ognuno sviluppa quello che è il proprio
il proprio nella creazione di questi
piatti e lui e the club
il porto lui come sempre perché lui è
praticamente paralizzato su questa sedia
motorizzata di cui andava fierissimo e
con questa sedia lui poteva fare
svariati movimenti di posizionamento del
corpo pur essendo lui immobile aveva
prescelto come suo strumento un erano
dei fili tipo dei lacci che lui
intingeva questo sistema motorizzato
della della sedia a rotelle all'interno
di un recipiente di colore e lì e le
disponeva poi sui piatti sempre con
questa sua tecnica che aveva sviluppato
il leaf meter diventa un segno ognuno di
loro perché ognuno di noi a determinati
alimenti fisici che sono in realtà però
possibilità di segno e quindi momenti
che raccontano qualcosa di autentico e
personale e questi per tutta quella che
poi la collezione di dati ne ha fin qui
vedete i suoi segni distintivi o quelli
di alina o quelli di merz che era più
uno scoppio
l'atto creativo conferisce valore e dà
anche la possibilità di affezionarsi di
più al contesto perché se iniziamo a
capire che tutto quello che ci circonda
è fatto in un determinato modo
c'è una storia allora iniziamo ad
affezionarci allo spazio che abbiamo
attorno
allora questo diventa un momento molto
importante di riscoperta del valore
personale e altrui e da un autorialità
una firma no perché bisogna avere
bisogna essere capaci di firmare le
proprie vite
questo contesto al mano mi chiamano
quartiere popolare e 500 famiglie
periferia di milano e fate qualcosa
io i miei studenti arriviamo in questo
luogo molto particolare
liti veramente pittoresche però quello
che faccio sempre buttare i miei
studenti in questa sorta di rapporto
immetto con le persone andate ognuno
voglia di relazionarsi all'altro
però c'è bisogno di agire c'è bisogno di
entrare nella nella scena con
propulsione nessuno ti rifiuterà se non
piccole cose all'inizio quindi
inizieranno a raccontarsi inizieranno a
portarci le mucche del caffè inizieranno
a creare situazioni conviviali e
dinamiche di grande forza e grande
potenza stare insieme significa anche
far sì che appaiano dei contrasti ma i
contrasti sono fondamentali nella
progettazione non è sempre idilliaco
c'è bisogno di gestire la complessità
quello che dico è nel momento che si
crea una crisi bisogna capire come con
tutto il nostro corpo porci e saperla
gestire
quindi si attivano dei team di lavoro e
facciamo sempre dei cantieri aperti in
maniera tale che gli altri possano
sempre sapere quelli che passano con le
mani indietro quelli li devono essere
con noi devono progettare e stare con
noi e chi non può brindare con nord
quanto meno e quindi poi abbiamo creato
arcipelago urbano che ha peste isole
mobili in cui le persone con delle luci
un cinema potevamo essere lì e stare
insieme creare un momento di festa
questa è una delle feste finali perché
la celebrazione di un momento è sempre
molto importante si eliminano dei gap
anche generazionali dello stare insieme
io ormai sono tutti i balli di gruppo
possibile inimmaginabili e questo è un
momento che io ho molto piacere a
condividere con voi perché ballavo
all'interno della festa di questo
momento finale sotto c'erano il rapper
di quartiere che che ci davano la musica
e ci fu un momento molto bello in cui
una signora venne da me e disse sarà che
bello c'è tutta questa questa energia
questa questo questa bellezza di stare
insieme e ti ringrazio per mia sorella e
la sorella mi indicava la persona che
stava ballando con me come una pazza
sudatissima e intonato sorella balla
benissimo mentre mi disse silk area ma
lei è sordomuta dalla nascita e non
sentiva una delle note che io realtà
stavo ballando con tanto amore
ma cosa succedeva in quel momento che la
cosa che mi colpì moltissimo
si creò quello che io definisco un
rapporto di osmosi energetica se voi
date in quell'azione ricevete quello che
state dando
e lei si fidavano seguiva quei movimenti
per sentire la musica e quindi andiamo a
ballare con i sordomuti corriamo per chi
non può occorrere andiamo a vedere i
tremonti con i persone ipovedenti e
perché prima non pensavo bene a questa
cosa e quindi in questo questo è un
momento in una scuola di the one mi
ricordo arrivai in questa in questa
materia ragazzi delle scuole elementari
e disse ragazzi facciamo due gruppi i
bambini si disposero dal più basso al
più alto in due file maschi femmine con
una un rigore una precisione notevoli e
capì che il mio workshop lì perché non
sempre cose immediate due giorni
allora ragazzi mi sa che faremo una
parata per esplorare il corpo e fargli
produrre della musica
[Musica]
attivandolo con degli strumenti musicali
che faremo con materiali di riciclo e
questo è un po un momento in cui
iniziamo a capire che per che
l'apprendimento signore è importante che
passi dal corpo questo è il nostro
canale ricettivo principale cioè le cose
passano da qua non arrivano le altre
parti ed era importante capire che quei
bambini che avevo visto molto spaventati
all'inizio nel confrontarsi dovevano
riattivarsi per entrare un po in gioco o
questo è un altro momento una delle due
ha 83 anni vorrei è un altro momento in
una periferia in cui andiamo a
relazionarci con gli anziani perché non
si progetta mai per qualcuno con cui non
si vive
bisogna capirne le necessità reali e la
signora per esempio nella zona ci ha
dato una grande lezione di vita il cui
faceva capire che i sentimenti non
invecchia possono invecchiare i nostri
corpi ma i nostri sentimenti no ed è
importante tenere attiva tutta questa
parte che noi abbiamo e non ce ne
dobbiamo dimenticare siamo vivi e i miei
studenti uno dei più grandi casquet mai
visti nella storia dell'umanità devono
approcciare a questo rapporto immediato
con le persone quindi i grandi nemici di
questo lavoro sono l'abbandono e
l'ignavia no quel pantano in cui certe
volte ci ritroviamo che ci rende
fatiscenti e squallidi invece questo è
un progetto per esempio che sono stato
da poco per ultimo camerino è una città
che è crollata durante il terremoto di
un anno e mezzo fa e per cui ci siamo
ritrovati a vivere quegli studenti nei
container luoghi molto anonimi e
l'anonimia non porta valore non porta
identità senza identità non andiamo
lontani quindi c'è sempre stato un
momento di ascolto bisogna sempre
ascoltare ciò che c'è intorno
le persone i luoghi le forme no cosa c'è
attorno a noi
ricavarne un alfabeto che poi ci porta a
progettare bisogna progettare bisogna
progettare con dei disegni bisogna
progettare facendo le cose con queste
braccia e in questo laboratorio abbiamo
creato una caciara mobile che è la
struttura che abbiamo portato in giro
per per la città di camerino includendo
chiunque noi trovassimo lungo il
percorso quindi camerino che
incredibilmente una città multiculturale
per la per l'università che c'è
questi ragazzi il ghana che studiavano
biologia e abbiamo iniziato a riattivare
questi luoghi dell'abbandono questi
luoghi che i camerti si sentono
disorientati perché sono stati
spodestati no da questo colpo di coda
che ha avuto la terra molto forte in
realtà se ne devono riappropriare
periferie centri devono capire questa è
la tendopoli che devono tornare a essere
nei propri luoghi nonostante il
terremoto e tutte le difficoltà e
viverlo dunque un'ultima cui voglio
parlarvi per esempio il condominio
perché quando io dico condominio voi
immaginerete liti funeste disagio quello
del piano di sopra che non sia mai lo
vedo in realtà io che detestava le liti
condominiali e poi ho deciso di
trasformarla quindi nel mio condominio
iniziato a creare questo rapporto
abbiamo trasformato il tutto e l'abbiamo
abbiamo iniziato io gioco sempre con
l'elemento di festa si deve fare la
festa
bisogna capire chi c'è davanti in un
luogo in cui nessuno si salutava quindi
questa è la prima festa di natale che
organizzato nell'androne e ho iniziato a
capire che tutto iniziava veramente
apprendere una dinamica iniziavo a
capire a sapere i nomi delle persone la
signora che mi portava le cotolette e
decidiamo con gli studenti di ricreare
il primo manuale di corteggiamento del
vicinato cioè iniziamo a capire come
entrare il rapporto con il vicinato
quelli che tutti i giorni vedi passare
davanti a te allora queste cose in cui
si riattivano garage torte sentimenti
crea un senso di appartenenza
noi dobbiamo sentirci appartenere a
qualcosa una comunità sia in maniera
individuale che collettiva e questi per
esempio dei concerti da balcone poi non
si capiva più niente un certo punto dopo
di che questo è un esercizio che io
faccio fare spesso i miei ragazzi e dico
avete un punto a e avete un punto b
tracciate un percorso
allora tutti si cimentano c'è chi va
direttamente a b chi fa del mega giri
per arrivare a b
chi sale prima nelle montagne poi arriva
chi è piccolo così in fondo nell'angolo
chi prova a b che torna subito chi fa
tutto un perimetro e poi c'è uno
studente indiano che dice sarà la b è
già contenuta nella e quindi il percorso
è già qui
questo fu un altro grande momento
potente nella mia nella mia carriera
perché capisco come effettivamente
abbiamo anche sempre tutto anche dentro
di lui ma dobbiamo sentirlo ere
attivarci e quindi bisogna donarsi
generosamente a se stessi in primis e
quindi agli altri e come ultima cosa
vorrei dedicare questo tech talk perché
appunto secondo me la vita è anche un
saper dedicare agli altri a un pazzo che
mi chiese lorenzo di sicuro che è un
ragazzo che soffre di distrofia
muscolare lo è paralizzato completamente
sulla sedia a rotelle però gli piace un
botto bob marley me dice sarà il ritmo
lo porto con il battito del cuore e mi
chiese di fare il regalo quindi se mi
fai la copertina del mio secondo libro
io non sono una grande non sapevo come
farla e decido andando a taiwan di
comprargli un berretto mega sobrio che
avrebbe messo e che volevo un grande
amante dei cappelli e di comprare del
pigmento indaco perché c'è juan la città
blu è piena di questi pigmenti e
tornai a casa milano nel mio studio misi
un foglio dispose il pigmento iniziai a
correre ho iniziato occorre per 10
chilometri di fila attivando indoor fine
passione tutto è tornata a casa
avrai dipinto questo foglio con il
sudore che mi era colato 10 km di corsa
volevo fare quasi un atto psicosomatico
e poi sarebbe nata dall'i la copertina
del suo libro lui tra l'altro mi
ringrazio tantissimo di sel sarà
bellissimo la copertina solo magari dopo
qualche spruzzata di deodorante però la
apprezzo molto e quindi io quello con
cui quello che vi voglio dire è un po
lasciarvi con l'immagine dello stormo di
questo che quando guardate gli stormi
che sono tutti questi non capite neanche
come fanno muoversi con quella con
quella sinergia nello stare insieme non
si scontrano ma sono individuali e
allora io vi chiedo sappiatevi donare
sappiate ascoltare gli altri
grazie
[Musica]